[Music]
I
[Music]
can't believe
hey don't worry Senora Becky
I'm not gonna steal your 200 Yogi pants
I will rescue this beautiful blender
though
[Music]
I mean what happened to Atletico brother
they choked
I wasn't coming to work to avoid your
silly grin
are the kids good my youngest she wants
to start a dance group with her friends
now I'm trying to save up to buy one of
those new Boombox speakers for a
birthday coming up she wanted to be a TJ
as long as she doesn't become a Chelsea
fan
you want me some Fufu
Rolex is hella Antiquated this Richard
Mill is what you need [ __ ] I'm too proud
for that
stuff
that's a weird kind of poverty
wanting more and more
never have been enough
that is for sure broken
but not poor
hey Jimmy when you're done check the
bathroom on five thanks
you got it
and they need broken people to keep
selling the dream
like this piece of [ __ ] phone
it's been begging for updates for years
they make everything ready to break
crack snap leak so they can just replace
and replace
newer shinier younger
five years for a computer
20 for a car 65 for a human if you're
lucky
[Music]
is like toilet paper
capitalism just like toilet paper
falls apart easily
what do you think it's Gonna Roll
forever
until the crisis hits
and it runs out and you realize
oh [ __ ] is this the only way to clean my
ass
when deal Sam's Army forced us out into
the jungle
I had to wipe my ass with leaves
sometimes newspaper
but I didn't miss toilet paper
no
I missed the days
foreign
people have something else next to their
toilet that sprays water on their ass
maybe there's something to it
[Music]
Gringos yeah I won't do it TP is freedom
is the American way of life
they get defensive and say oh it doesn't
work
but have they really given it a try
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how many plates for that suitcase right
there
[Music]
the last the master
even the broken
everyone is useful
almost everything can be repaired
and have purpose
that's what we all need purpose
[Music]
foreign
welcome to 5432 idle line who are you
visiting today
where's Stephen
Stephen is not a valid request please
try again
where's Stephen
what have you done
you can't keep getting rid of us
you can't just throw away people
in your
puppet presidents starve us
and you get mad at us because we come
here to survive
what the [ __ ]
but we don't complain
never
we just work all day and all night
like a [ __ ] machine
but we're still not good enough are we
not not machine enough so people become
disposable
like it's better to be plastic or a toy
or [ __ ] punching bag
that's why we hold on to things
because I can't hold on to people
anymore
they all get
fired deported or replaced please try
again
I can't do it
it's too [ __ ] painful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
now
[Music]